Where does a great idea come from?
In my experience, it all starts with a single spark.
That's how we became the creatures of the night.
Something small, but bright.
Maybe something only visible to one person.
Hush, little one.
Let me sing you to sleep.
Moonlight has come,
Now, drift off to a dream.
That might be something. Did you get that
one?
Guys! Wake up! Don and Clifford going to
be here in an hour. Jesus.
Howard, what do we have for our producers?
We have one complete song, 11 fragments, and
25 rough notions screamed over piano chords.
Maybe one night wasn't enough time to
write a whole show.
Are you kidding?
One night in 1978, I wrote two
musicals in George Plimpton's bathroom.
Or was it one musical in two nights? It's all
pretty hazy. The point is, Norman Mailer
punched me in the mouth, and when I woke up,
I was in Betty Friedan's waterbed.
I love that story. Hey, Oliver. Quick crazy thought. My cousin, Moses Morris, he's very big at State Farm insurance.
Howard, did you notice how when I told a
story, it had recognizable names and a point?
No.
Moses Morris runs sponsorships for State
Farm. So let's say I gave him a ring. Maybe
they sponsor the musical, and then we don't
even need Donna and Cliff. Bam!
We don't need your- Moses Morris?
Yeah.
Everything we need is right here.
Look at this cast.
They're all killers.
As we look at the cast, we are faced with an
unsettling truth. Any one of them could be
the killer.
Any notes?
Oliver always gives me notes on my reads.
I thought it was fine.
Oh, Oliver would be a little more snarky.
Do you want me to- Okay.
Excellent. Charles. This time, try it with a
dash of none of what you just did.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, God, I miss him.